hello everyone and welcome to the moment
that I've been waiting for my entire
life
Godzilla versus King Kong this will be
the greatest sporting event of all time
our matchup is as epic as the Super Bowl
it's as big as the World Cup and it's
like the ancient Olympics because the
competitors are completely naked oh my
god oh my god here's how it works
round number one box office round number
two tomato meter round three powers and
then we'll do a wild-card round to help
settle the dust I'll throw my two cents
in along the way is probably gonna be
like four cents for this vid but
ultimately you will decide the fate of
these two legendary beasts number one
box office we find ourselves on the
precipice of Godzilla king of the
monsters which is gonna set up Godzilla
vs. Kong in 2020 and those films have a
long way to go to be the most dominant
in the celebrated history of these
legends now Godzilla jumps out to an
early lead simply based on number of
films he's got 36 total two Kong's nine
however both fellas only have four films
each with reliable box office numbers
and Kong actually gets the crown of best
total domestic box office seven hundred
nine million dollars to Godzilla's five
hundred and seven million dollars and
best average box office also goes to
Kong a hundred and seventy seven million
dollars to the lizard's 127 million
dollars so the great ape should win this
round easily right not so fast
Kong is fighting out of Skull Island but
he does his best box-office damage in
North America Godzilla also does well
here but he's fighting out of Japan and
he crushes that box office as well so to
render a verdict this will come down to
the highest gross for one individual
film and Godzilla made 262 million
dollars with 1998's guides oh really we
have to talk about that oh god it was so
bad whoa this is what a Nick
gets shot with an everyday
the 2005 peter jackson king kong is at
304 million dollars so skull island's
favorite son wins round number one round
two tomato meter kong is up 1 but I fear
we have awoken a sleeping giant we call
him Godzilla not only loves destruction
at fire he's also a fan of getting good
reviews of the 30 movies we have scores
for him on the tomato meter his average
is an almost fresh 58% his average
stands above Kong's 7 film average that
is fifty five point five percent so Kong
does have the highest ranked film of
either competitor on the tomato meter
with the 1933 classic that started it
all King Kong at 98 percent shout out
Fay Wray however Kong also has the
lowest rated movie on the tomato meter
King Kong lives and he guesses to its
core it's a quote Animal House mr. blue
tarski 0.20 really that's a shame
because I saw that movie in the theater
when I was like 5 and I loved it it's
great let's start a hashtag hashtag Kong
for life we'll work on it later alright
I'm calling this round godzilla gets the
win he's on the board and we got us a
tied ball game heading into round 3 he
looks angry
round 3 powers what I love about both
these gentlemen is that they don't just
rely on their massive size to wreak
havoc and cause mass destruction they
have actual abilities to Godzilla is
known as the Thunder wizard for a reason
his headlining special power is atomic
breath and it is nasty
he can summon fire from his belly and
doesn't have to eat a sriracha burger to
do so
Godzilla also excels at regeneration
mutation radiation absorption and even
monster telepathy from Godzilla 1994
plus he's an excellent swimmer he's got
a very fluid breaststroke I really want
to see what his backstroke looks that's
my stuff if you don't know how King Kong
can compete with a fire-breathing
radiation soaking dinosaur then you're
under estimating Kong's raw athletic
ability he is super strength tremendous
speed is a great climber and he boasts a
perfect form on the single leg takedown
and when he's done battled Godzone in
the past he's shown some nice immunities
in 1962's King Khan vs. Godzilla his fur
was impervious to flame and he was able
to draw strength from electricity
electricity makes him stronger no one
talked about neutralizing Godzilla
now the 1998 Godzilla had the famous tag
line size does matter that actually
might be the only thing good about that
film Godzilla's height can range from
355 feet as in the 2014 iteration all
the way to 984 feet in the 2017 anime
Godzilla planet of the monsters
meanwhile will Kong
he was just 147 feet in Godzilla vs.
King Kong and he shrunk to a mere 100
feet in Kong Skull Island he is not tall
enough to ride this ride or is he when
these two beasts did tangle before Kong
appeared to win at least in the version
that ran here in the United States they
both went in the water at the end but
only Kong surfaced hmm and look forgive
me if I sound like a baseball purist
here but Kong does all this naturally ok
Godzilla is the very definition of
artificial enhancement he was made by
nuclear stuff so it may look cool but
it's also cheating it's like when
Captain America cheated when I got all
those Super Soldier abilities oh that's
a hot take everything special about you
look Kong did it the way mother nature
intended and that's why he gets the
upset win in this round now it's time
for a wild card round competition
Godzilla needs this one to tie so we'll
take a close look at it who have you
played in the past which one of our boys
has been going against top level
heavyweights and who's been pummeling a
bunch of tomato cans : mostly plays home
games on Skull Island and there he's
done battle with skull crawlers they
killed his entire family okay
squids even robot King Kong now he got
lucky to scape that one with his life
but the marquee matchup on Skull Island
has been Kong vs. t-rex I don't know the
t-rex his name is there's been a bunch
of them any t-rex counts he's fought him
badly of him over the decades but he
always emerges wounded and victorious
and then I guess he eats him it's what I
imagine he does I bet they taste like
Kirk Godzilla ain't fighting any turkeys
listen to this who's who of opponents
Hedorah
Mew tous biollante ring any bells
okay how about gigging destoroyah
Mechagodzilla King Ghidorah Rodin Mothra
the script for 1998 Godzilla yeah Wow
Godzilla's done battle across continents
regularly and his fighting has often
been done to defend us planet Earth
promote to really scary creatures Kong
more often than not he's just fighting
on behalf of a young human lady he's
sweet on and I don't really know how
that first date works godzilla wins this
round easily he's fought tons of
headliners and charles barkley remember
that ad campaign
Godzilla's round Rex packs in the early
90s do your homework kids okay so it's a
tie Kong and Godzilla each got two
rounds for me but I have to declare a
winner and I think I'm going with my
heart
now look Godzilla you're an absolute gem
my life would not be the same without
you but I think Kong is king in the end
his smarts and his quickness is gonna
get the best of you he got two rounds
today and he helped kick everything that
we love off way back in 1933 King Kong
you're the winner just in my book
this is just my opinion
now it's your vote you are gonna
determine the true winner here all you
have to do head to the comment section
right now and let us know who wins in
your mind and we'll tally it up what a
day this was you know some folks dream
of making a ton of money starting a
family me
I just wanted to announce a Congress as
Godzilla match and today a young boy's
dream came true thanks for watching
everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]